il n'y a que les piétons qui ont accès à
l'intersection des rues young & fitch
et pourtant ils sont venus par centaines
toute la journée sans arrêt fleurs à la
main et les larmes aux yeux
impossible de ne pas s'arrêter le temps
de réfléchir ou de prier devant autant
de peine et autant de malheurs
luma aurait pu être une de celles que
l'on pleure aujourd'hui elle sortait du
djembé hier et s'y retrouver debout
devant les cadart bouche bée elle
tremble juste à penser à la scène et
pour tous ceux et celles qui ont
littéralement été écrasée au passage du
camion des pauvres passants que le
hasard a choisi et qui n'avait aucune
chance de s'en sortir
anne-marie de miku travailler sur la rue
lyon dans une firme d'investissement
elle était sortie pour la pause du midi
et elle n'est jamais revenue
une femme plein de vie et de chaleur son
collègue de travail
il n'y a pas de mots pour dire à quel
point elle va nous manquer parmi les
autres victimes
dorothy shaw moore elle avait 80 ans et
deux jeunes coréenne qui résidait au
canada dont il travaillait justice et
aux petits foutraque du coin nature
elle était dans la vingtaine elle
travaillait fort souriait tout le temps
sa famille est encore et il en bas ça
n'arrive pas à joindre ses parents
je propose office of the elle est morte
mais pourquoi exactement quel était le
motif les autorités ont bel et bien
confirmé que la grande majorité des
victimes sont des femmes âgées de 20 à
85 ans il faudra du temps pour
identifier les corps le processus est
long et douloureux
tout comme le sont ces histoires que les
témoins racontent encore ébranlés mais
cette abstention la référence comme
celle d'un couple âgé qui promenait un
enfant quand ils ont été frappés
violemment
l'enfant est resté seul le conducteur
n'a pas que tu aies hier il a traumatisé
toute une communauté
et c'est d'une tristesse infinie de
cette jeune femme même si c'est à nice
un événement isolé pour toronto
est ce que il faut s'habituer à ce genre
d' atteinte vous êtes européenne vous le
savez c'est des gens qui utilisent leur
voiture qu'il y ait un camion je ne peux
pas le contrôler il n'ya pas il n'ya pas
des façons de le contrôler simo nadal
theuriau est émue elle se sait
aujourd'hui chanceuse d'être là en vie
j'étais là cinq minutes avant
car peut-être c'est le destin
il n'y a pas de logique et elle se
devait de revenir rendre hommage aux
disparus et à ceux qui se battent pour
leur vie ici tamara alter escaut radio
canada toronto